sitting and I'm thinking I'm thinking
while I'm sitting I thought we was tight
but some dudes they be switching my dogs
to the right we gonna be all right them
boys that left dating going to switch
sides life is full of Trials try again
if you fail and lies in the world make
the truth
click clack gunshot Mama try and call
the cops I've been ringing like slashing
guns still blasting for the Y in front
of Jesus between love for no Kardashian
you probably didn't get that your car
like no six-pack no Nikes
more green than the bay Pack's my best
and it's evident I swear my flow is
Heaven Sent rich boy Legos cause I'll be
stacking presidents cause green I see it
clearly trying to stack into the
stealing like Bob I'll be building and
I'm graphing on the million but I'm
plotting on the billion Life's good how
you living guaranteed be winning
[Music]